[Applaudissements]
une foule compacte
un cortège monstre qui défilent dans les
rues d'alger et convergent vers la
grande poste du symbolique épicentre du
mouvement depuis le début
après huit semaines consécutives de
manifestations
la mécanique est bien huilée des slogans
bien rodé
parfois ironique souvent décisif
à peine nommé le nouveau chef de l'état
par intérim
abdelkader bensalah 77 ans est devenue
la cible préférée des manifestants qui
le prie de dégager ça fait plus de
trente ans depuis la l'indépendance on a
toujours les mêmes têtes les mêmes
personnes qui gouvernent ce pays
nous ce qu'on veut on veut un
rajeunissement du système de canada 1 un
premier ministre jeunes pourquoi pas
l'algérie misisi dénonce la mainmise de
clans sur le pouvoir et souhaite un
changement en profondeur
saïd fergani parcours chaque semaine 200
km pour venir se faire entendre à alger
tous les vendredis cela pour bénéficier
pour dire à ce système mafieux corrompu
de dégager le peuple algérien en amas
s'affaissait 37 ans qui sont au pouvoir
on va pas lâcher ils vont partir ils
doivent partir pour leurs intérêts et
pour notre intérêt hakim kouider lui est
venue du canada
rien pour manifester après quelques
rassemblements devant le consulat
d'algérie à montréal il est senti le
besoin de se rapprocher de ses racines
l'algérie a besoin de tous les algériens
d'ici qui habite en algérie et au visage
et rien qui habitent à l'extérieur du
mal géré et ils ont besoin de tous à
tous les agents et francis apprend
l'union ce qui me plaît de tout ça si tu
sais d'union depuis une semaine les
algériens appelaient à une mobilisation
record convaincu que seul un nombre sans
précédent de manifestants était en
mesure de faire plier le gouvernement
une démonstration de force la légitimité
par le nom et une manifestation
familiale bon enfant sourire aux lèvres
mais en fin de journée alors que se
dispersent les manifestants
une autre démonstration de force
neuf cette fois ci des autorités
discrète et en retrait jusque là les
forces de l'ordre passent à l'offensive
nuage de gaz lacrymogène et chars de
l'escouade antiémeute bientôt rejointe
par le ghost le groupe des opérations
spéciales de la police nationale une
unité d'élite plutôt entraîné à
combattre les terroristes bilan de
l'intervention une vingtaine de blessés
et une centaine d'arrestations
mais au milieu du chaos imperturbable un
groupe de jeunes bénévoles donnent
l'exemple en ramassant les déchets à
l'image de la nouvelle algérie dont il
reste aujourd'hui qu'ils espèrent libre
démocratique mais aussi ici jean
françois bélanger radio-canada à jour